The Syrex Array 10, this will tell inflammation and inflammatory issues, can you explain?
Is this a blood work test? Who does this? Sorry, just saw that in the cheek swab and wanted to
work. So the Syrex Array 10 is a blood test. So if you order it off our website, we will send you
the kit and then you'll have to go get a draw. So where do you go get a draw? Well,
you could go get a draw at your local doctor, at your, at pretty much any clinic. There's draw
centers, you know, around everybody. So most people know that you can go get a draw somewhere.
But if you have a trouble with that, let us know. What does the Syrex Array 10 tell us about
inflammation? So the Syrex Array 10 is tested for antibodies to food. It's tested 100 different foods,
many of them cooked, raw, different types of how you would eat that specific peptide protein,
substance, and if you have, you know, let's say you're eating different foods that are,
that you have antibodies against every time you eat that food, whether you feel, you know,
stomach upset or not, because most time you won't, it's causing an inflammatory response. And when
you get that inflammatory response, you're going to have systemic inflammation and you have systemic
inflammation, it's going to be harder to heal from anything. So go eat your food sensitivities
is highly beneficial because you can help decrease systemic overall body inflammation. And you could
help heal from all sorts of things. So if you are eating, let's say we do a Syrex 10 and let's say,
you know, cashews and so it reads them. I'll have some sample Syrex 10 readouts on the courses.
So on the autoimmune course, if you go to the product disease and autoimmune course, I have videos
explaining the different Syrex antibody tests and videos explaining the Syrex Array 10 as well.
But how it reads it out is greed is normal, yellow is, you know, outside of normal and red is
abnormal. Beating that you have a lot of antibodies against that thing when we're talking about foods.
So let's pretend that that cashews were in the red zone for you. And you just happen to eat cashews,
you know, maybe even on a daily basis. Every time you eat cashews, you're causing inflammatory
reaction of the gut, which can cause all sorts of gut problems and dysbiosis and all sorts of things.
That's how you evaluate somebody, you know, for symptoms and gut disorders and stuff. But from a
cancer perspective, that's also going to cause inflammation systemically in the body. It's the
cause inflammation of the brain as well. So it's really hard to, you know, heal from cancer
when you're dealing with systemic, when you're causing systemic inflammation of a daily basis by
eating foods that you have antibodies against. So and then when you eat foods that you're causing
this inflammatory reaction, that inflammation is from these chemicals called cytokines
and chemokines. And then you're actually stealing your immune system away from killing cancer
to have to deal with this, with this reaction against this food antibody that you're exposing yourself to.
So the reason why a person may want to do a food sensitivity test, why do I have to look at food
sensitivities? I don't have gut problems. I have prostate cancer, I have breast cancer for good
to say, well, okay, we're trying to heal the breast cancer, prostate cancer, lymphoma, or whatever
you're trying to heal, and you're causing all this inflammation every time you eat and you're stealing
away energy from your immune system dealing with this inflammatory response. It's going to be a lot
harder to deal with cancer, and it's going to make things get worse. So that's why. So sometimes when
I do cheek swab testing, it got inflammation comes up, and that's, I may suggest the Cyrexia rate 10 for people.